e
[Música]
[Aplausos]
alguna vez releyendo la biografía de sor
juana inés de la cruz me encontré con
una imagen que quedó dando vueltas en mi
cabeza en mucho tiempo una escena donde
una mujer erudita va saliendo de un
juicio de la santa inquisición con las
manos atadas caminando detrás de un
carro de caballos en señal de escarnio
por haberse atrevido a pensar y no
solamente eso sino haberse atrevido a
publicarlo a ponerlo en letras han
pasado casi 400 años de aquello y las
cosas han cambiado para nosotras las
mujeres ahora tenemos derecho a entrar a
una universidad tenemos derecho a decir
ya publicar lo que pensamos tenemos
derecho a votar sin embargo me pregunto
si las cosas han cambiado tanto para
nosotras y la respuesta es sí pero hay
un punto en donde todavía seguimos sin
mantener el equilibrio y este es el
asunto de la crianza nos aparece
entonces creo cuando yo hablo con las
mujeres de mi entorno con mis pacientes
con mis alumnas que tenemos dentro de
nosotros uno
llamada por mi rabia ancestral es como
si tuviéramos que vengarnos de lo que
pasó a las mujeres que nos antecedieron
y si bien hemos alcanzado muchas cosas
en el ámbito de lo social y de lo
público en la parte de lo privado
pareciera ser como si tuviéramos la
obligación de vengarnos de lo que pasó
antes y encontramos un punto de manera
inconsciente un punto muy clave donde
esta venganza se puede ejercer y esto es
la crianza porque me estoy yendo hacia
la crianza porque cuando hablamos con
cuando yo hablo con estas mujeres me
platican esto de tengo ganas de triunfar
en la profesión pero entonces tengo que
quitar un espacio de tiempo a mis hijos
y si bien puedo darles tiempo de calidad
no es todo el tiempo que yo quisiera
darles quisiera darles mucho más pero no
me alcanza y si dejo la profesión por un
lado entonces me siento con la sensación
de no alcance lo que yo quería
nos vemos metidas entonces entre dos
fuerzas
nos impulsan a buscar una forma de
solución esta rabia ancestral nos lleva
también a pensar que nuestros compañeros
de vida son quienes tienen la culpa y
justamente ahí en la crianza es donde
podemos ejecutar la venganza de la que
ni siquiera nos estamos dando cuenta
porque lo podemos hacer ahí porque la
vinculación con los hijos es distinto
entre un padre y su hijo y entre una
madre y su hijo
entre en una madre y su hijo la
vinculación se hace de manera biológica
natural podríamos decir y entre un padre
y su hijo necesitamos de la conducta
necesitamos de la voluntad y no
solamente la de ellos necesitamos de la
voluntad también de la madre de ese hijo
cuando nosotros engendramos entonces
tenemos una comunicación muy temprana
con nuestros hijos desde el momento en
que estamos justo engendrando hay una
comunicación química que lleva a ese
bebé a llegar de un espacio extrauterino
a dentro del útero para que se mantenga
ahí se mantenga seguro y protegido hasta
que nazca también algo que hacemos es
una tolerancia inmunológica para que
siendo un cuerpo extraño y un micro
cuerpo extraño dentro de nosotros no lo
maten nuestro sistema inmune sino se
mantenga vivo hasta el momento de nacer
pero además tenemos la ventaja de sentir
el movimiento fetal cuando más o menos
tienen cuatro meses nuestros pequeños
sin hacer nada podemos sentir cómo se
mueve nuestro vientre y está embarazada
sabe esa maravilla de sentir un cuerpo
que está creciendo dentro de nosotros
que se está desarrollando y que además
es alguien totalmente individual a
nosotros distinto
los varones no tienen esa bendición
nuestros varones tienen que pedir
permiso para tocar ese vientre nuestros
varones tienen que tener la voluntad de
acercarse ese vientre y tocarlo
desde ahí entonces podemos ver que
nuestro poder con los hijos es mucho más
grande que el de ellos desde ese
entonces cuando todavía no hay
abstracción cuando todavía no hay
pensamiento podemos ejecutar cosas que
también inclusive ni siquiera las
podemos pensar hay una palabrita que se
llama microclima mismo que nos vincula
fuertísimo con nuestros hijos esto
quiere decir que las células fetales
atraviesan el corriente sanguíneo de la
mama
y tiene tenemos células de nuestros
hijos dando vueltas en nuestra sangre y
que sirven además para cerrar heridas y
literalmente ayudan por ejemplo en el
posparto a que se cierren las heridas
del parto a reparar tejidos de la mama y
eso no se hace una vinculación sumamente
fuerte porque es real aquello de que
nuestros hijos son sangre de nuestra
sangre y nosotros somos sangre de ellos
porque las células de nuestros hijos
pueden entrar en médula ósea y pueden
producir células sanguíneas en nosotras
también pueden hacer cambios a nivel
cerebral y en la actualidad se está
hablando inclusive de que pueden
modificar las emociones de esta mamá
emociones que tienen que ver con esta
con este favor de mirarlos y de unirnos
con ellos en una vinculación sumamente
fuerte
el cerebro cambia en una mamá de ser por
ahí diría algún autor una carrera y teri
está rural se convierte en una autopista
de cuatro carriles tenemos conexiones
sinápticas distintas mucho más rápidas
para atender de manera eficaz todas las
cosas que tenemos que ver cuando estamos
creando un pequeño la oxitocina tiene un
papel muy importante y la prolactina
tiene un papel muy importante para hacer
una vinculación con este niño y también
para tener una sensación de placer de
poderlo cuidar hay una parte de nuestro
cerebro el prefrontal orbitofrontal y la
ínsula que tienen que ver con conocer
cómo está este pequeñito quién necesita
en nosotras para podernos vincular y eso
nos podría responder porque algunas
mamás no pueden hacer una buena
vinculación porque algunas veces esa
estructura está dañada y tiene que ver
con las ancestras tiene que ver con cómo
fuimos creadas y con toda la cultura que
nosotros recibimos
en los padres es distinto en los padres
tenemos que tener decía yo la voluntad y
tenemos que tener conducta para poder
establecer la vinculación no es
puramente biológico y desde ahí pues la
relación con mamá las feromonas de la
madre en el sistema del papá tiene que
ver con esta aceptación por esta
relación o no y también el olfato ahora
que lo toque es sumamente importante ya
que una mamá en gestación huele a su
huele a su compañero estas partículas
odoríferas de este varón suben a su
nariz se deshacen entran al moco pasan
al torrente sanguíneo llegan al líquido
amniótico y en el líquido amniótico en
el vientre el bebé puede oler a su papá
solo que lo huele asociado con la
emoción que esa mamá tiene no es
entonces su emoción
es una emoción prestada volvemos otra
vez a pensar que tan poderosas son las
mujeres cuando ese niño nace va a
asociar ese olor de ese papá con una
emoción que no es suya es una emoción
prestada en el cerebro del papá también
va a haber cambios por ejemplo tres
semanas antes del parto la testosterona
baja y el cortisol sube para que para
que ese papá esté más tranquilo y para
que entonces pueda atender cualquier
vicisitud que se pueda presentar para
cuidar a su mujer ya su pequeñito la
biología está bien hecha
esto va a regresar a lo normal cuando el
niño sea capaz de caminar estamos
hablando entre 9 meses y 12 meses
posparto y podemos también entender por
qué los papás sedes afanan más
rápidamente de sus hijos entre comillas
y las mamás somos más aprensivas tienen
un cerebro distinto al nuestro y hay
otro punto en donde también las mamás
tenemos mayor influencia los hijos nos
reconocen a través de la voz y del olor
pero no a través de la visión es hasta
los tres meses de edad posterior al
parto que los niños tienen maduración de
la vía visual y de esta manera pueden
reconocer visualmente a su papá le
llevamos mucha ventaja entonces sin
embargo yo me quedo pensando en estudios
que hay acerca del apego adulto seguro
el apego adulto aseguró es cuando
sabemos que el mundo es un lugar seguro
que tenemos una base segura para
enfrentarnos a todo lo que el mundo nos
pone y hay estudios que nos dicen que
cuando un hijo supo sintió percibió una
mayor calidez paterna puede más
fácilmente hacer un vínculo seguro
qué pasa con nuestros pequeñitos y esto
no ocurre pues pasa que los mantenemos
en un estado y pegar' usal eso quiere
decir que su cerebro está expuesto al
estrés todo el tiempo y va a tener
modificaciones estructurales importantes
como cuáles como por ejemplo el
prefrontal este tiene muchísimo que ver
con la relación entre estos dos figuras
entre papá y mamá entre el cuidado que
me dieron entre la satisfacción de las
necesidades que yo tenía el prefrontal
es sumamente importante para poder tomar
determinaciones porque es el que hace el
juicio y el análisis de todo lo que
vamos a decidir durante toda nuestra
vida así sea
me pongo estos zapatos o no así hasta
juicios y hasta decisiones trascendentes
en nuestra vida y en los primeros 18
meses es sumamente importante
mantenernos en calma en estabilidad para
poder establecer este circuito adecuado
de sinapsis en en el cerebro
si nosotros le ofrecemos al cerebro de
nuestros pequeños la misma cantidad de
buenos nutrientes que de afecto lo que
vamos a obtener es un neurodesarrollo
adecuado deseado bajar y si tenemos ese
neurodesarrollo bien plantado entonces
podremos tener un vínculo seguro
nuestros hijos se podrán parar en el
mundo bien firmes ofreciendo una forma
distinta de relación con los demás
ofreciendo una nueva manera de vernos en
comunidad de sentirnos seguros de lo que
estamos haciendo en fin de ofrecer
ciudadanos de mejor calidad al futuro
por eso entonces pienso en aquella
metáfora de los hijos como pájaros y
pienso que los hijos tienen que volar y
trascender pero para poder hacer un
vuelo adecuado para volar con toda su
plenitud necesitan igual que los dos
pájaros que los pájaros dos alas para
volar muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]